[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر
الله يبارك فيك
[موسيقى]
واعدامات النظام تثير الغضب الدولي
[تصفيق]
كورونا الذي امتد ثلاث سنوات وسلطات
تتوقعوا ملياري رحله جويه
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
تلفزيونيه لترويجي للكتاب العائله
[موسيقى]
الاوكرانيه لكنها لم تدمر المباني
التي قالت روسيا انها تستضيف جنود
الاوكرانيين وتم تدميرها تقول ان هذه
المباني لم تصب بصواريخ مباشره والاضرار
بها ليس جسيمه هذه المشاهد صورتها رويترز
للمباني التي تقول موسكو انها قصافتها ان
نوافذ تبدو محطمه واثار لقذائف على الارض
ورغم هذه الاضرار
السلطات الاوبرانيه قالت انها لم ترصد ايه
هجوم روسيا على تركناه واكدت ان روسيا لا
تمتلك القدره علشان ضرب بهذه
الدقهليه اوقفت ايواء القوات بالقرب من
بعضها البعض في المنشات بعد الهجوم الذي
شنته بدايه العام خوفا من ضرب روسيا
انتقاميا لكن روسيا متمس
كه
للعسكريين الروس في مكه نفذناه عمليات
التقنيه خلال الساعات ال 40 الماضيه على
قواعد للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده كرامتهرس
وكان هناك اكثر من 700 عسكريين اوكراني في
المهجه رقم 28 واكثر من 600 اخرين في
العنبر رقم 47 ونتيجه لهجوم صاروقي مكثف
على هذه المواقع قتل اكثر من 600 جنديا
اوكرانيا
ومعنى من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
وكذلك
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر اهلا بكما
ونبدا معك حذيفه حول اخر المعلومات
الوارده من الجانب الاوكراني فيما يتعلق
بهذا الرفض الاوكراني للروايه الروسيه اي
تفاصيل اضافيه
في المساء وكذلك علق على هذه الانباء من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي حول قصف همم منطقه
الكرامه موتورز وتحديدا سكن عسكريا همم
اوكرانيه وقال سرجيه الشرفاتي وهو المتحدث
باسم القوات في الشرق قال ان هذه المناطق
هي عباره عن همم
سكنيه وكذلك همم بني تحتيه تحديدا او
منشئتين تعليمتين ولم يكن هذا المكان [__]
اي جنود اوكرانيين وان هذه المعلومات هي
معلومات كاذبه من قبل الاتحاد الروسي وقال
ايضا ان هذا ياتي مقصود به الداخل الروسي
وياتي ردا يعني
لتحسين صوره الاتحاد الروسي بعد الضرب
الكبيره والموجعه التي تلقتها روسيا من
قبل الجيش الاوكراني في مكيفكه وقتل عدد
كبير من الجنود الروس وهذا الامر محظو كذب
وافتراء هذا ما اتى في بيان هيئه الاركان
المشتركه حول هذه الحادثه
انتقل الى مراسلنا رائد الاخبار من
دونالدز رائد يعني هل هنالك من تفاصيل
اكثر حول الضربه الروسيه لانه هناك حديث
بانها ليست ضربه واحده بل ضربتين في
منطقتين مختلفتين
راويه مساء الخير لكي و الا طاهر ولحذيفه
بالفعل اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن ضربتين من
المقاتلات الروسيه التي اعلنت عنها الدفاع
اصلا سابقا بانه سيكون هناك تطور
بالعمليات العسكريه في ااا محور دانيت
ولجانس كالمحور الشرقي حيث ان المقاتلات
الاستراتيجيات ستدخل نطاق العمل في
العمليه العسكريه بالفعل اعلنت عن اصابه
موقعين قالت بانهما بالفعل المناطق مدنيه
لكنها تست الاعداد كبيره من الجنود
الاوكرانيا وقالت بان 600 قتيل اسفر عن
همم يعني اسفرت عن تلك الضربتين وان كل
ضربه همم منهما استهدفت 700 مقابل في احد
همم المواقع و600 مقاتل في الموقع الاخر
كما ان هناك من هم همم يعني اصابات كثيره
تركت خلفت هذه الضربه لكن الاهم من ذلك
اذا سمح
الوح
شمال المقاطعه بالفعل هناك معارك باريا
الق الروسيه قوات باجنر وقوات الشيشانيه
القوات الخاصه
دخلت مناطق في مدينه بلده سيدار على اطراف
المدينه من الناحيه الشماليه وسيطرت على
نقطه هامه نقطه استراتيجيه تدعى بادكروني
وهي مستعده لتطويق المدينه من الناحيه
الشماليه لتكمل الطوب حيث انها بالاصل
تطوق من المناطق الجنوبيه والشرقيه والان
تفوقها من الناحيه الش
ماليه
الفعل يعني عاده المعارك والقذف العنيق من
قبل الطرفين قسم متبادل نسمع دويا
لانفجارات
وصوت اطلاق الصواريخ والقذائف منذ الصباح
الباكر وحتى الان بالفعل ربما تعود
المعارك الى وضع يكون اعلى من سابقا شكرا
جزيلا لكما حذيفه الاخبار
التي وصلتنا قبل قليل
اقتحام
لمناصري الرئيس البرازيلي السابق بولس
سونارو لاقتحامهم مبنى الكونجرس وايضا
القصر الرئاسيه
لويس اناثي
باولو همم
انصار الرئيس السابق يعني سونار يقتحمون
مبنى وزاره وقصر الرئاسه في العاصمه
برازيليا هذه اخر المعلومات
37 للمره الاولى بعد خمسه ايام من تنصيبه
متحدثا عن اهم الصعبه لاعاده بناء البلاد
هذا هو الشعار الذي يتخذه الان
راويه
المتحده الامريكيه على خلفيه ايضا نتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه وقتها همم نذكر بان
وقت تنصيب همم الرئيس البرازيلي لولا
رئيسا للبرازيل همم جرت حفل جرى حفل
التنصيب باجراءات امنيه همم مشدده وهذه هي
المره الثالثه التي يتولى فيها حكم
البرازيل الا ان فوزه بهذه الانتخابات
تحديدا اثارات جدلا داخل الشارع البرازيلي
بين مؤيد ومعارض
ثم نعود الى هذه التطورات خاصه اذا جده
فيها جديد
والى بخمود التي تحولت المعركه فيها
لمعركه كسر عظم بين القوات الاوكرانيه
ونظرتها الروسيه التي حاولت وفشلت على ما
يبدو في تحقيق اختراق كبير في المدينه
لتسلم المهمه لمن لمرتزقه مجموعه
المواليه للكرام لن تحاصر القوات
الاوكرانيه وحققت اختراقا باتجاه قلب
المدينه وفق ما نقل معهد دراسات الحرب عن
مصادر روسيه ومدونين عسكريين موالينا
لموسكو زعم احد المدونين الروس ان تجمعات
القوات الاوكرانيه في بخموت باتت متوقعه
في مؤكد ممول مجموعه فاجنر جوزين انا قوته
حسره هي التي حققت هذه المكاسب دون اي
مسانده من القوات الروسيه التي هاجم
قياداتها بشده القى بريجوزين باللوم على
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لعدم قدرتها على
تحقيق مكاسب في محمود وقال في مقابله مع
وسائل اعلام روسيه ان قوته لم تتقدم في
المدينه لان الجيش الروسي لم يقم بتطهير
المباني امر اثار رداد فعل سلبيه لدى
المسؤولين الروس وفق معهد دراسات الحرب
الامريكي خصوصا بعد انتشار مقطع فيديو
بالقرب من بخموت لمرتزقه فاجنر وهم يشتمون
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه فاليري جراسي موفا ويشكونا من نقص
الذخيره في معاركهم
قبل ايام ظهر مؤسس بعدنا في خطي الجبهه في
محمود كما نرى في هذا الفيديو وهو يراقب
جثث عناصره مكدسه بالاكياس قال ان الجميع
يريد ان يعرف متى سنسيطر على مخنوق الا ان
كل منزل اصبح حصدا واضعف بريجوزين يقاتل
رجالنا احيانا لاكثر من يوم كامل لسيطره
على منزل واحد وفي بعض الاحيان تدور
المعارك لاسابيع على منزل واحد وكل عشره
امتار هناك خط دفاعي اوكراني يبغيني
اختراق الدفاع يعني اختراق الدفاعي منزل
واحد ثم عليك ان تكسر دفاع المنزل التالي
اليس كذلك هو ليس مجرد خط الدفاع واحد كم
عدد خطوط الدفاع الموجوده اذا قلنا 500
فسيكون ذلك دقيقا اليس كذلك
سابقا
تعطي صاعدا بين اجنحه الكرام لن يا طاهر
على الارض خلافات انتقلت من الخفاء الى
العلم لكن التقدم الحاصل اليوم ان صح قد
يخفف من حده هذه الازمه بين الطرفين
يشير الى ان القتال الدمار الحرب كل شيء
مستمر لا نيه لدى بوتن للتراجع ولا لدى
الاوكرانيين
نيه للاستسلام لاحلام القيصر مقاله مشترك
كتبته وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه السابقه
ووزير دفاع السابق روبرتغيتس في صحيفه
واشنطن بوست تحدث فيها عن نيه بوتن سيطره
على كاملي اوكرانيا وان لم يحقق ذلك في
يريد تدميرها كدوله قابله للحياه يرى
المسؤولان الامريكيان رفيعان السابقان ان
بوتن يعتقد ان مهمته الاساسيه هي اعاده
تاسيس الامبراطوريه الروسيه الامريكي
منذ سنوات فانه لا يمكن ان تكون هناك
امبراطوريه روسيه من دون اوكرانيا عول سيد
الكامل على ارهاق الاوكرانيين وتلاشي وحده
الغرب بمواجهه حرب على جارته الغربيه لكن
الوضع الحالي هو ان الاقتصاد الروسي
والشعب سيعانيان كثيرا مع استمرار الحرب
رئيس وجيتسا يا ريان ان الهزيمه ليست
خيارا بالنسبه لبوتن ولا يمكنه ان يتنازل
لاوكرانيا عن المقاطعات الشرقيه الاربعه
التي اعلن انها جزء من روسيا وانه اعتمد
خلال سنوات على الصبر لتحقيق اهدافه
لكنهما حذرات من انه على رغم رد الاوكراني
البطولي الا ان اقتصاد البلاد في حاله من
الفوضى وقد فرى الملايين من السكان ودمرت
البنيه التحتيه اضافه الى ان كثيرا من
الثروه المعدنيه والقدره الصناعيه الكبيره
والاراضي الزراعيه باتت تحت السيطره
الروسيه
وفي غياب اختراق اوكراني كبير ضد القوات
الروسيه ستزداد الضغوط الضغوط الغربيه على
كياف للتفاوض على وقف لاطلاق النار مع
مرور اشهر من الجمود العسكري وفي ظل ظروف
الحاليه فان اي اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار من
شانه ان يترك القوات الروسيه في وضع قوي
لاستئناف حربها عندما تكون جاهزه
تقول رئيس وزير الدفاع السابق في مقالهما
ان خطاب الرئيس الاوكراني ميرسي امام
الكونجرس الشهر الماضي ذكرهما بمناشده
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق واستنتشر
في فبراير من عام 41 حين قال اعطونا
الادوات وسننهي المهمه وابدا كل من رايس
وجيتس توافقا مع تصميم اداره على تجنب
المواجهه المباشره مع روسيا لكنهما قال
انه مع ذلك قد لا يمنح بوتن هذا الخيار
للولايات المتحده وان طريقه تجنب المواجهه
مع روسيا في المستقبل هي مساعده اوكرانيا
على سد الغزو الان تنهي رايس مقالها
المشترك مع جيت بالقول هذا هو درس التاريخ
الذي ينبغي ان يوجهنا وهو يطفي حازم ملحه
على الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها قبل فوات
الاوان يقول مدون عسكري روسي شهير انهم لا
يؤمنون بوجود دوله اسمها اوكرانيا وان
المفاوضات والهدن امر غبي بمناسبه دينيه
في اشاره الى الهدنه التي تمت في عيد
الميلاد الارثوذكسى وانه يجب انهاء المهمه
وهو بالضبط ما ردت به موسكو فهديه اعياد
الميلاد من روسيا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
كما يقول نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسيه متر مدفادف انها الفرقاطه
التي اعلن بوتن عن اطلاقها قبل ايام لتبحر
بالقرب من شواطئ دول حلف شمال الاطلسي هذه
الفرقه تصفها روسيا بانها سفينه حربيه
متعدده الاغراض ومزوده باسلحه صاروخيه
موجهه ومصممه للقيام بمهمات في البحار
والمحيطات
الفرقاطه قادره على حمل صواريخ مختلفه من
طراز كاليبر وكينغال وتسيركون وكروز لم
تعلن روسيا ما اذا كانت ستبحر في اطار
مجموعه من القطاع البحريه لكنها اعلنت ان
الفرقاطه بها انظمه دفاع جويه قادره على
حمايتها من التهديدات تبحر الفرقاطه اذا
بعد تدشينها في رحله طويله تمر عبر المحيط
الاط ثم تدخل البحر الابيض المتوسط وبعد
ذلك تنتقل الى المحيط الهندي يوم تدشينها
اطلقت صاروخا تجريبيا من طراز سيركون
الفرس الصوتيه من مياه بارنت سي لتصيب
هدفا في البحر المتوسط نتحدث عن مسافه
تقدر ب 4000 كلم الصاروخ سيقان هذا قادر
على التحليق بسرعه بسرعه تزيد عن 11 كلم
في الساعه بمعنى انه يستطيع القيام بدوره
كامله حول الارض في اقل من اربع ساعات
سرعته الخارقه تجعله قادرا على الهرب من
اي نظام دفاع جوي في العالم وتقول موسكو
انه لا نظير له في اي مكان وهو قادر على
حمل رؤوس حربيه مختلفه بالتاكيد منها
الرؤوس النوويه كما يمكن اطلاقه من البر
والبحر
[موسيقى]
وانا تابع واياكم مشاهدينا من هذه الصور
اقتحام القصر الرئيسي في العاصمه
البرازيليه البرازيليه اذان متابعه هذه
الصور ونذكر بانه تم اقتحام القصر والعديد
من المباني الوزارات والكونغرس كذلك في
برازيليه من قبل انصار رئيس البرازيل
السابق اليمني
مقابل او بعد ايام على تنصيب له لادا
سيلفا اليسار مجددا في حكم البرازيل اذا
نشاهد هذه الصور لمكتب
الرئيس البرازيلي همم السابق طبعا
الحليب ولكن الاقتحام هو من مناصري الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق اذا نشاهد تحطيم طاهر
للغرف الطاولات
واخر المعلومات تقول بانه متواجد فيه
كنا نذكر يوم التنصيب بانه كان هناك
تهديدات كثيره من قبل المناص الذي توجه
الى الولايات المتحده لكي يتفادى تسلم
والتسليم بين بينه وبين لولا ده سيلفا
طبعا يعني نتحدث عن
ولايتين كان همم فيهما الاقتصاد البرازيلي
هشام جدا خاصه
وتضخم همم يعني يبدو مع رغم عوده الاولى
بانه همم تحديات ستبقى همم على ما كانت
عليه رغم كل وعوده
اذا نتابع اي صور جديده في حال ورودها
قبل قليل ان المحتاجين اقتحموا ايضا
للسيارات في قصر بلانالتو الرئاسي واللي
وصلوا بعد الكونجرس هو اللي كنا نرى صوره
قبل قليل واللي يوصله بعدما يعني قام
باداء اليمين في الكونجرس في يوم التنصيب
ورئيس البرازيل الحالي
[موسيقى]
رسميه حاليا لولايه ساو باولو اذا لم يكن
هناك ولكن الكثير من التداعيتهم
القصر الرئاسي المحكمه العليا
تتابعونا بعد الفاصل
الدنمارك وهولندا تستدعيان سفيري ايران
على خلفيه تنفيذ احكام اعدام ضد
المتظاهرين وسجنوا لي فائزه رفتا جاني خمس
سنوات لتايدها الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نقلت مصادر اعلاميه
ايرانيه صدور حكم قضائي بالسجن خمس سنوات
بحق الفائزه هاشم رفس جاني وهي ابنه
الرئيس الاسبق هاشمي راس سان جاني عقب
بطولها امام محكمه للنظر بالتهام الموجهه
اليها وكانت فائزه رخصه جاني قد حكم عليها
سابقا بالحبس سته اشهر ومنعها خمس سنوات
من ممارسه الانشطه السياسيه والثقافيه
وصحفيه لارتكابها جريمه النشاط الدعائي ضد
النظام على حد وصفاء وكانت السلطات اوقفت
رافت جاني في سبتمبر الماضي بشبهه التحريض
على الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت امين وذلك عبر
مقطع فيديو نشرته
الان كل ما يحدث في الداخلي والخارج كل
هذا بسبب ضعف حكومتنا وليس لاي منهم اي حل
لتعويض عن الوضع الراهن او لا يبدو انهم
قاده فاعلون وقادرون على قياده الدوله نحو
الاصلاح وحل الازمات لذا فعلوا ما يظهروا
قوتهم للتعويض عن هذا الضعف العميق
الهولنديه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي الى فعل شيء نفسه
نفسه
من عقوبات حقوق الانسان ضد ايران وزاره
الخارجيه انها ستدعي السفير الايراني على
خلفيه اعدام المتظاهرين واوضح وزير
الخارجيه
الاستدعاء اوضح ان قرار الاستدعاء هدفه
ارساله رسائل قويه للنظام الايراني
هذا هو تظاهر اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شخص وسط
لندن رغم الامطار الغزيره للاحتجاج ضد
استخدام العنف وقم الاحتجاجات في ايران
في بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده احتجاجا على تنفيذ
احكام الاعدامات ضد المتظاهرين
ومعنى الان من باريس محمود مراد
اهلا بك معنا سيد مراد خادمي في العربيه
360 اريد ان اسالك اولا عن طبيعه العلاقه
العائليه مع مرشد ايران علي خامنه ايه
وبها معارضون كيف يتعامل همم هو شخصيا مع
مثل هذا الامر همم وكيف تتعاطون معه عموما
او هل تصلون رسائل له او يفسر رسائل لكم
مثلا دعنا في اجواء هذه الجزئيه لو تكرمت
قبل ان تابع
مساء الخير
صحيح
امنائي هذا المنصب ليس لديه علاقات مباشره
معه والدته التي كانت تشارك احيانا في بعض
اللقاءات لم تعد تتصل بشقيققيقه همزه عام
2009 منذ المظاهرات وقتل المتظاهرين
كما ذكرتم في هذه
النشره هناك اعضاء في النظام واعضاء في
عائله
يعاردون ما يقوم به النظام الاسير ما في
ما يتعلق
بالحمله القمع التي تتم باوامرها من علي
خامئي طيب سيد محمود يعني هل انتم همم من
العائله المقربه فقط الذين ربما تعارضون
ااا يقوم به مرشد ايران من
ممارسات سياسيه وايضا الان همم العنف
الممارس ضد المتظاهرين يعني
حدثنا عن ال- ال- الافراد العائله الاخرين
يعني ما طبيعه العلاقه مع مرشد ايران
اي علاقات مهما كانت مع المرشد وكما قلت
لكم فان والدتي قطعت علاقاتها مع احمد
عامر 2009 وهناك اعضاء اخرون في العائله
احيانا يتواصلون معه ولكن بالنسبه
وهو من الاصلاحيين الذين لا يتواصل معه
لانه قال علنا بان علي خلينا ان لم يعد
السماء اليه اليه وبالتالي عندما لا يستمع
اليه فقط
لانه يتمنى موقفا ديكتاتوريه وهو ليس ما
الى اي شخص كان
همم كنت اقصد بسؤالي هل المعارضه داخل
العائله كبيره ام انه تقتصر عليكم انتم
كعائله
بالنسبه
لعائلتي كما تعلمين على خير مينائي كان
كان تلميذ عند والدي في النظام القديم
وكان معارضا كبير كبير ويمكن ان
نقارنا والدتي مع منتظري فهو كان همم
مقربا من عده اشهر من الثوره الايرانيه
اصبح معارضا للثوره وبتاع ده عنا النظام
وعزف عني المشاركه في النظام انه دائما
قال ان النظام الفقيه لا يجب ان يحكم
ايران وهو ذاته لم يكن لديه الرغبه في ان
يشارك في الحكومه
والخميني طالب منها
ان ياتي الى طهران للمشاركه في الحكومه
لكنه رفض ذلك لانه
لديها افكار علمانيه على الرغم من انه كان
متديننا اذا ومن خلال والدي همم ورثنا
شجاعه همم
[موسيقى]
ومعارضه وافكار
معارضه ونحن
التزم كثير بما بدينا ولا نقبل ان نتبنى
موقفا مختلفا وهذا ما نظهره دائما وابدا
نتبنى مواقف مناهضه لنظام الملالي همم هل
همم القرابه تشفع لك بطريقه او باخرى همم
انك تتلقى تهديدات وبالتالي همم تحرس
امنيه وتوفر لك الحمايه ضد همم يعني تنفيذ
اي ان من هذه التهديدات
كوميدي
عندما وصل الى
منصب كبير المشتهدين او منصب الاجتهاد
اسامي او ايه الله حظ يا هو على
الحمايه لا يمكن
ذلك
كان محيقا وقد كان يتواصل معه منذ سنوات
يقول لي الثوره وكان يدركه انه والدك كان
على حق على الرغم ممم ما قال له بشان
العراق فهو لم نريد ان يتعرض للخطر
واخميني لم يريد ان يكون هناك اراك للدماء
في الاسره ونحن نحاول ان نستغل هذه
الحصانه النسبيه وانه كافه
منذ قدومي الى فرنسا عام
1986 ولا سيما منذ عام 2000 لما توقف عني
المشاركه في همم حركات احتجاجيه وتعزيز
المعارضه وكذلك تقديم المساعده
للشباب لصوني
الحريه والعلمانيه وفصل الدين يعني الدوله
والسياسه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
اذا طهر الى هذه الصور في البرازيل
الاقتحام انصار الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جير بول سانيرو القصر الرئاسي وايضا لمبنى
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا وعدد ايضا من
الوزارات بالعاصمه برازيليا نبكر بانه هذه
هذا الاقتحام ياتي بعد اسبوع من تنصيب
الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا ااه طبعا انه كان
سبق ذلك فرد لقوات الامن في البرازيل فوق
على المباني الحكوميه طوقا امنيا لكن مع
خروج المئات من المتظاهرين
يعني الاعتراض على وصول الرئيس سيلفا
المتظاهرين تمكنوا من كسر هذا التوقيت
الامني واقتحام القصر الرئاسي والكونغرس
كمان نشاهد في هذه الصور جمع غفيره عدد
كبيره جدا يا طاهر صحيح جدا وهي كما قلنا
قبل قليل تذكر
مبنى الكونجرس في واشنطن همم وقد حلت
الذكرى الثانيه هذه الايام في السادس من
يناير من 20-21 على اثر رفض وناصريه
ترامبو نتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه ومن
المعروف سونارو وترامب يعتبر
ويعني وينتهي جان الخط على نفسه تقريبا في
العديد من القضايا هو نتحدث عن يعني
يمينيين هنا التعبير بالمعنى السياسي
والبطونار وكان يتوجه الى الولايات
المتحده عندما تسلم او عندما كان يجب ان
يتسلم منه همم الوشاح الرئاسيه في تقليد
تسلم وتسليم السلطه في البرازيل ولكن هذا
لم يحصل الا ان الولاده سيلفا ادى اليمين
الدستوريه صور قوى الامن وهي تحاول ان تصد
المتظاهرين بعدما اقتحم المئات من مناصره
همم الرئيس السابق بوت سونارو مقررات
السلطات الرئيسيه في البرازيليه
الكومبرس والمحكمه العليا وكذلك قصر
بلانالدو الرئاسيه
وقد تسببه بالكثير من الاضرار راويه
همم الشيوخ المؤقت فينيزيانو فيتال دو
ريغو قال لشبكه سي ان ان برازيل ان ال
متظاهرين وصلوا الى القاعه الخضراء
الواقعه خارج غرف مجلس النواب الكونجرس
ونجحوا باقتحام المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا
وايضا قصر بلند بلانت له الرئاسي همم
نشاهد الان هذه الصور الخارجيه صور همم
اقتحام من الخارج اذن الانصار كل سناره
يقتحمون القصر الرئاسي والمحكمه العليا
والكونغرس في البرازيل انه نذكر ايضا بانه
الرئيس البرازيلي همم
السابق جيرمان هو الان يتواجد بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فيما الرئيس الحالي في
ثوب
اخرى اذا بعد على فوزه او بعد التسللمه
المنصب بايام وبعد عقده الاجتماع
الذين همم شددوا جميعا على ضروره اعاده
بناء البلاد كالش شعار رئاسي في هذه
الولايه الثالثه ولو بعد انقطاع لي لولا
سيلفا همم وطبعا كانت تنصيب منذ اسبوع
تقريبا
للمره الثالثه وقد ادى اليمين في الكونجرس
ومن ثم توجه الى القصر
وكلاهما تحم همم هذا اليوم من قبل مناصري
بونسونارو ما الذي سيترتب على ذلك الان
سياسيا امنيا قضائيا كثير من الاسئله
اقتحام الكابيتال هي الان يعني يدفع ثمنها
انصار وايضا الرئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من جديد انه
نذاكر بانه الاولى عندما ادى اليمين
الدستوريه يوم الاحد الماضي همم
تعهد بانه لا يسعى الانتقام لكنه سيطبق
القانون همم اذا هذه صور يعني تاريخيه من
البرازيل تصلنا للحشود بالمئات من انصار
الرئيس البرازيلي السابق يا ايوب سونارو
يطالبون باستقاله لولا ده سيلفا طبعا كان
هؤلاء يحتاجون على فكره راويه ربما لم تكن
صورهم سلطه كثيرا عليهم عالميا الا انهم
يحتاجون منذ
سيلفا في الجوله الثانيه على بوسونارو في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
الثلاثين من اكتوبر بل وقاموا بالكثير
اطلق الكثير من التهديدات همم فيما يتعلق
بهذا الامر الا ان المسار السياسي استمر
حتى اقسم الولاده سلفا اليمين عائدا الى
السلطه بعد اليمنيه وهي عوده لليسار على
كل حكم البرازيل على اثر فوز الاولى
كانت ايام الشرطه البرازيليه قد اعتقلت
احد انصار بول سنارو بتهمه وضعه لمتفجرات
في شاحنه وقود بالقرب من مطار بالعاصمه
عشيه الميلاد
وقال الرجل وقتها بانه يامل بزرع الفوضى
قبيل حفل تنصيب لولا وانضم الينا من سان
باولو هانئ الدرسان الصحه في اهلا بك سيد
هاني يعني مشاهداتك لهذا لهذا الاقتحام
يعني بماذا ينبا الى اي مرحله تذهب
البرازيل الان
سيد هاني هل تسمعني
اذن و الى حين جهود الاتصال مع سيد هاني
نشاهد هذه الصور طاهر لي انصار اذا الرئيس
البرازيل السابق بول سانيرو وهم يقتحمون
مباني حكوميه عده ويطالبون باستقاله لولاد
دا سيلفا سيد هاني هل تسمعني
هل تسمعني جميعا
الذي ذكرنا بحادثه اقتحام الكابيتل الى
اين تتجه الامور الان بالبرازيل
البرازيل لم تشهد البرازيل مسبقا
هذا النوع من
غير ديمقراطيه كما تسمى في بعض الصحف
البرازيليه قبل قليل
هذا المشهد غير مقلوب هذا المشهد سوف يكون
له سريعات سياسيه كبيره كانت تهديدات
مصطفى
رئيسيه ولكن للامانه لم يتوقع الجميع
كيف تفسر تمكن انصار بوت سونارو من فعل
ذلك الان والرئيس في صوت باولو كما تقول
المعلومات وليس في العاصمه
هل هناك كانت دعوات كثيره تجمع
الايام
القيامه مثل هذا النوع من الاحتجاجات
والانهم يحاولون محاصره المركز الرئيسي من
خلال
تقوم بما يتمكن من هو مسموح لها لمنعه
واضحه
الان من فعل ذلك بعد الفوز وبعد التنصيب
وهو في ساو باولو هل يشيل ذلك
بتورط او تواطئ مسؤولين همم حتى لو على
مستويات منخفضه في داخل السلطه ربما من
انصار بونسونارو
طبعا بالنسبه لموسوناري هنالك له انصار في
في جميع المستويات
السوشي طبعا
فوز الرئيس ولكن هذا هذا التطور المتطور
خطير على الصعيد السياسي في فرنسا
على اي ابواب يفتح الباب هل على مزيد من
العنف على مزيد من التراجع ال- الاقتصادي
يعني كان ذكر زميلنا طاهر بانه اصلا
ومعروف بانه الان هناك تضخم عالي جدا
بالبرازيل وايضا ولكن الذي اود ان اسالك
عنه فعليا هو ما قاله بول سونارو خلال
ادانته للاحتجاجات على هزيمته في
الانتخابات دعا وقتها انصار الى اظهار
بانه همم باننا مختلفون عن الطرف الاخر
ونحترم الاعراف والدستور وبالتالي هل ذلك
يعد ربما تنصلا من هذه همم من اعمال العنف
الذي تحصل هذه
بالضبط هذا كان نوع من انواع الرسائل
السياسيه التي اصدرها
وذلك من اجل
الحد من الضغط
بس همم فمن الصعب ان يكون هنالك اي ادله
همم تثبت توائط سوناريو بشكل مباشر في
دعوه الى هذا ولكن انصروا كما ذكرت لكم
سابقا لديهم قوه دعنا نسميها وناعم في
السوشيال ميديا لديهم مجموعه كبيره تدعو
الى تدعو الى تجمعات الحجاجيه بشكل دائم
ذلك الامر يعني التواضع عليه منذ بدايه
صدور نتائج
بالانتخابات
ولكن اليوم كانت نقلا نوعيه في محاولتهم
لامتحان
الرئاسي
هل في تصريح عم حاول تشوف على تويتر
لم يصرح بعد على تويتر هل في اي تصريحات
همم منه او من مسؤوليه
منصات اخرى
لحد الان لا توجد اي نوع من انواع
التصريحات المباشر ولكن خلال الساعات
القليله بكل تاكيد سوف تصدر تصريحات اعتقد
حتى من
الانصار السياسيين الذين تول مناصب سياسيه
ضمن الحكومه دون سيلفا ايضا من التاكيد
سوف يصنع بعض الاعلانات
على هذا النوع من الاعمال التي تمر عليها
الاعمال
ااا الاحتجاجات والتجمعات هي شيء قانوني
ولكن الغير قانوني في هذا الامر هو اقتحام
المراكز الحكوميه هذا الشيء سوف يكون له
اثر كبير جدا حتى على التصاريح المتعلقه
على الاحتجاجات التي سوف
القصر الرئاسي المحكمه العليا وايضا
الكونجرس هل كان متوقعا لانه قبل ذلك ذكرت
بمعلومه عن اعتقال الشرطه لاحد انصار
بورسنارو بتهمه وضعه متفجرات امام احد
المطارات وقال لها صراحه اريد زرع الفوضى
الى حفل تنصيب لولا يعني هل هذه الاحداث
هي ممهجه محضره ربما
الحدث الذي اول الحادثه التي
تمت في ليله اعياد الميلاد اما لقاء القبض
على هذا الشخص لمحاول الوضع قنبله متفجره
وكان يحاول بي ان يقوم بالتنسيق مع عدد من
افراد الجيش والشرطه لعمل اعمال
الامر تم الاعلان عنهم من خلال الصحف لقاء
القبض عليه تم شبه تعتيني
مؤشرات الى وجود بعض المخططات التابعه
للانصار
الرئيس السابق
حاولت منهم لي العوده الى الحكم بطريقه
الاصل لديه خلفيه عسكريه لديه انصار في
الجيش لديه انصار بالشرطه وطبعا لحد اليوم
الانصار التابعين المصدره لم يتقبلوا
النتيجه التي حصل عليها امام
على الموضوع معك استاذ هاني شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات هاني الدرسان الصحفي
[موسيقى]
بعد العاصفه التي اثارها كتاب الامير هاري
نزل الملك تشارلز الثالث
ان يتحدث وان التزام الصمت لم يكن ليجعل
الامور افضل
بشؤون الملكيه في بريطانيا ان هذا الكتاب
ادخل العائله المالكه في اكبر ازماتها منذ
المسلسل الذي عرض في التسعينات وتناول
انهيار زواج من الاميره الراحله ديانا
الكتاب الذي فتح النار على العائله
الملكيه يتحدث عن كيف تعاطى الامير
البريطاني المخدرات وكيف حاول مع اخيه
ويليام اقناعه والده بعدم الزواج بكامل
التي اصبحت الان الملكه القرينه احتل
الكتاب المرتبه الاولى على قائمه الكتب
الاكثر مبيعا على موقع امازون في بريطانيا
حيث اتاح الموقع طلب الكتاب قبل موعدنا
الشرهه فعلا كثيره اثارها الامير هاري
وزوجته ماجن ماركل يرصدها لنا مراسلنا من
لندن مصطفى زارو اليك مصطفى
كتاب سيره الامير هاري
ولقائه
المرتقبثيران المزيد من الجدل وسط ترقب
كشفه عن المزيد من التفاصيل والمزاعم طالت
افراد العائله الملكيه الامير هاري قال
بانه بكى مره واحده فقط بعد وفاه والده
والدته بسبب تفضيل العائله لذلك واصفا
مشاعر الذنب في مقتطف من مقابله التي
ستعرض الليله في وقت لاحق لنتابع
الجميع كان يشعر بانه يعرف اما انا اقرب
شخصين اليها وهم الشخصان الاكثر حبا لها
لم يتمكنها من اظهار عاطفته ما في تلك
اللحظه
حتى الان عن كتابه واللقاءات المروجه له
يتوقع ان يزيد التوتر في الاسره الملكيه
وخاصه مع شقيقه الامير وليام ولي العهد
البريطاني الذي اتهموه بادائه جسديا بشان
زوجه الامير هاري ووصفها بانها صعبه وقحه
بحسب ما جاء في صحيفه الجارديان التي حصلت
على نسخه من الكتاب
[موسيقى]
اتهاماته لافراد العائله الملكيه
والتصرفاته غير الاخلاقيه في سن مراهقته
واعلان قتله ل 25 من مقاتل الطالبان لن
تكون نهايه سرد تفاصيل حياه امير كانت
تصفه الصحف الشعبيه البريطانيه بالامير
الشقي الذي يدق الى حمايه خصوصيته وخصوصيه
زوجته بعد ازمات وفضائح مدويه لكنه اليوم
يبحث عن التشهير من كاليفورنيا حيث يعيش
مع عائلته لكن صورتها ليست الوحيده
المتضرره فالعائله باكملها وتقول كثر
النائب كاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملك تشارلز
الثالث ان هذه المذكرات قد تكون بدايه
نهايه للعائله الملكه
ورغم كل الانتقادات التي واجهها هاري
لوالده وشقيقه يقول الرجل انه لا يزال
يريد الصلح الكره في ملعبهم هناك الكثير
لمناقشه وامل ان يكونوا على استعداد
للجلوس والتحدث
تصف الجارديان ما يحدث الان في العائله
الملكيه بانه صراع اشقاء قد يؤدي الى
تفكيك واحده من اقوى العائله في العالم
وتقول ان الشقيقين هاري وليم كبرى في السن
لكنهما لم يمضج بعد وسيطرت مشاعر همم
المشاعر ال- ال- الحسد والعدوان وهي مشاعر
طبيعيه في فتره الطفوله لكنها خطيره عند
التقدم في السن هو ابلغ ما يدل على خطارها
ما جاء في في كتاب الامير بان الملك
تشارلز الملك تشارلز الثالث قال لابنيئه
ارجوكم يا اولاد
اتركوا حياتي الاخيره يعني سعيده وان لا
تكون بائسه
شكرا جزيلا لك مصطفى ازارو مراسل العربيه
من لندن تحياتي اليك شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اوقعت المباراه المنتظره بين فريق مختلط
الهلال والنصر ضد باريس سان جيرمان اللجنه
المنظمه في حرج بسبب الاقبال غير المتوقع
على تذاكر المباراه
من داخل السعوديه وخارجها ماقد او قاد
اللجنه الى اتخاذ قرار بنقل المباراه الى
اكبر ملاعب العاصمه استاذ الملك فهد الذي
يتسعوا لنحو
75000 متفرج ويتراقب عشاق كره القدم
المباراه راويه التي ستقام في التاسعه عشر
من يناير الحالي على كاس موسم الرياض
بوجود النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
وبوجود ايضا
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن عبر
الهاتف تركي ال الشيخ رئيس هيئه الترفيه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اهلا بك
معالي المستشار يعني ماذا ستفعلون امام
هذا الطلب الكبير والمتزايد على تذاكر
المباراه العدد وصل الى الان حتى مليونيه
طلب
مساء الخير عليكم
في البدايه توضيح بسيط من البدايه نحن
مقرريننا استاد الملك فهد
ااا
دره الملاعب في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اهتم فيها هذا المباراه
يعني
هذا اندلل على شيء الا على
ان هذه النتائج نقطه من من من محيط وليس
بحر محيط نتائج رؤيه
سيدي همم رئيس مجلس الوزراء ولي العهد
الرؤيه همم الحمد لله رب العالمين اخبار
الغير طبيعي غير مسبوق همم يعني انا في
تليفونات همم
مباشره ومتواصله سته من عندنا نتيجه الظهر
غير مسبوق
كان في تاخير في السيستاني طلب من اكثر من
170 دوله حول العالم
تجاوزنا اثنين مليون طلب وقفنا لما همم
وقفنا عند هذا الرقم لو استمرينا لا استمر
هذا الرقم كان بيني وبين اخويا همم
ناصر الخليفي
نادي باريس سان جيرمان اتصال كنا له يعني
تكررت هذه المباراه بالضبط الى مبالغه 100
مره في موسم الرياض لا ذهبت سولد اوت هذا
تاريخ رقم تاريخي حتى في تاريخ طلبات
تذاكر باريس سان جيرمان وسرعه الطلبات همم
اكرر الشكر والانتماء
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين حرمه الله
واللي تموتي قائدنا المنوع الراضي الرؤيه
اي والله ثم وصل هذه
الاحداث التاريخيه التي تحصل في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
واحده من اهم عواصم العالم
الرياض الحمد لله والشكر ولا قلت اقول لكم
انا في احراج انا فعلا بلا مبالغه ااه
جميع هواتفي تم اغلاقها انا
متعرض للاحراج كبير
بالسبعين الف وال 80000 رساله واتساب
ما استطيع ان اتعامل مع الجميع
لكن ان شاء الله يتم الحدث ان شاء الله
بشكل فيهم وان شاء الله يليق بموسم الرياض
باذن الله مع المستشار ما حدث كما قلت
حضرتك رقم قياسي لم يحدث في بطولات كبرى
اضافه الى الانجازات والارقام القياسيه
التي تم تحقيقها في موسم الرياض هذا
يسعدنا جميعا بدون شك ولكن يزيد من
التحديات من الصعوبات التي يمكن ان
تواجهكم في المواسم المقبله
صحيح
كل صعوبات لها حل ايه
بقياده
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين وتسمى سيدي
رئيس مجلس الوزراء ولي العهد رؤيه لا لن
نواجه اي اشكاليه او او اي مصائب كل مشكله
احنا لها حل بهذا الدعم لا محدود لكل
القطاعات في البلد همم
مهمتين النقطه الاولى
همم شكرا خاص
يا سمو امير قطر وااا لاخي ناصر الخليفي
اللي بنو فريق ايضا همم مثل البريد باريس
سان جيرمان همم اعتقد الذي ستكون همم نقطه
مفصليه همم في شعبيه ما قبل المباراه وما
بعد المباراه في الشرق الاوسط انا كان
الان في تواصل مع اخوي ناصر الخليفي ومع
المسؤولين فريق سان جيرمان بدنا طلبات
التيشرتات همم لباريس سان جيرمان ثلاثه
اجبال يعني طلبنا اعلان كميه التي طلبناها
وانا اعتقد انها سنطلب المزيد
شكرا جزيلا لتواجدك معنا الليله رغم ضغوط
ورغم اقفالك لكل خطوتك بسبب الحرج اللي
قلته انك وقعت فيه
نقطه في نقطه هنا في نقطه مهمه
بتال لا يعطيكم معلومات غلط مباراه من
الاساس يستعد الملك فهد
الى صوتك شكرا
كان بالاساس تم اختيار استاذ الملك فهد
شكرا جزيلا لك معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ رئيس هيئه الترفيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
اليوم في العربيه 360 من مدينه شنغهاي
الصينيه التي بدات تتعامل مع انهاء قرارات
كورونا داخل الصين الصوره من داخل مطار
شنغهاي للعمال الذين بداوا في ازاله
الحواجز الخاصه الحجر الصحي للوصلين الى
مطار المدينه
مع وصول البلاد
وفيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من اليابان
لتدريبات عسكريه لاربعه الجيوش تريد
توجيهها الرساله للصين
والاستراليه تدريبات للقوات المحموله جوا
لمحاكاه عمليه الانزال
المظليات الانزال نحو انف جندي وعشرون
طائره اضافه الى مركبات عسكري
وهكذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الساعه لكن
الاخبار لا تتوقف ننتقل الى الزميل صهيب
معه اخبار الساعه وريم وراويه وليال رجعوا
بيوم واحد بس نعم عوده الفريق اذا الحمد
لله على السلامه يا راويه وكل عام وانتم
بخير طبعا انا وطاهر كنا متوليين المهمه
طبعا خبر الساعه طاهر وراويه سيبقى طبعا
ما يحدث في البرازيل يربوا اننا امام
انقلاب هناك في ظل غياب الرئيس المنتخب هو
موجود في صوته همم انصار الرئيس
والمحكمه العليا وكذلك القصر الرئاسه
نتابع المزيد في اخبار السابعه اليك
[موسيقى]